300 families over 1 000 orphans are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products the website is in
the description link below you can also
use the discount code salam 10 for 10
of their products salaam alaikum
brothers and sisters and differences
hope you guys are willing before i start
i want to praise allah subhanahu wa with
allah the most most for the most trust
of praise is glory and gratitude belong
to him and today's video i'm going to
get straight into inshallah is about
brother shum idris and his wife um this
video was sent to me as you can see on
the screen i don't know for these three
videos i actually haven't had no clue
what the person that followed it to me
was even saying that i don't know what
you're talking about um so some people
come to me and said you know like expose
them etc
um and i want to make something very
clear about sisters yeah fast i'm going
to play two videos one's going to be of
his wife froggy
the second one is of himself and i want
to make something very clear i i do not
intend or i do not look for people's
mistakes because i feel allah subhanahu
wa tala the process adam said if
a person looks for the sins of his
brother allah will find his sins in his
house so we shouldn't be people looking
for like oh how can i catch this person
now well this is this is a disease in
the heart yeah now i could use this
opportunity if i had this disease in the
heart uh i have many diseases male i'll
protect me i'm just talking about the
specific one and mail that protects me
from this as well um that i could have
easily make this and go full out on them
because there's many things that they do
that is not permissible yeah i could
have got full out on them and use this
on top and just send hate towards them
and you know the video could go like
that yeah i could just say you know what
you guys are like this you guys are like
that you fake the whole thing
etc the question that i would have to
ask myself is why would i do that yeah
why would i do that why am i doing it
because genuinely care or because i ever
hate uh inside me towards them i have a
disease i just don't like them because
of whatever it may be let's go to the
video this is a video that of
this couple who's gone to
a place to eat
and they are claiming that they suffered
islamophobia
let's first listen to the wife i'm going
to blur her face the reason i'm going to
blow her face robot in a sense i'm going
to blur it because she's somebody's wife
she's married and she's you know when
makeup you should beautify herself so i
prefer not to you know see that as i'm
listening um
yeah so let's go into it we just got
back from dimitri's which is a dessert
cafe it's in oakville we went to the
oakville location it's in ontario canada
i took my kids my family and some of my
hijabi friends we just wanted to have
some dessert just have a night out you
know how people go out
the servers at that location
did not want to take our order they
asked us to leave the
restaurant and if we didn't leave the
restaurant they said they will call the
cops which they did because we didn't
want to leave
because we were muslim and they didn't
want to take our order okay now that's a
big claim it is very distressing for
anyone that suffers from islamophobia
and we deal this head-on you know with
islamophobes in the uk and et cetera
around the world
that we try to expose um so it's a big
claim
but there was a message from another
individual another sister
who claimed that she was at the
restaurant herself
she claims that
that's not how it unfolded etc but let's
carry on we're going to find out what
really happened we're going to come to
understand inshallah what really
happened and as muslims how we should be
behaving towards this kind of claims
after going to a public restaurant just
to have some food especially with a baby
told to leave along with my hijabi
friends
and my family because we were muslim and
we were a hijab this is so disgusting i
just want to make sure it doesn't happen
to anyone again um and obviously there
are certain people that are contesting
that as well let's see what uh brother
idris has to say because he brings some
evidence forward i'll be explaining
everything with facts so make sure you
watch this video till the end i've been
on social media since 2012 and the last
nine years i have never talked about a
brand like this publicly and honestly i
had no intentions of doing so but after
what we experienced that night i really
wanted to share everything with you guys
now i want to clarify that i've been to
dmitry's plenty of times in the past as
a matter of fact in the past it was my
favorite dessert place to go to i have
never experienced racism i have never
experienced any islamophobia in the past
and i celebrated my wife's birthday
party at dimitri a group of 11 people
that arrived at dmitry's around 1105 pm
now keep in mind that this group
consisted of three hijabis a 10 year old
and an 18 month old baby
muhammad our friend his mom fatima
wanted to treat us so she got in the
line she even got a text message while
we waited in the rain for our table to
be ready the timing of this message is
very important because some staff
members and people claim that we walked
in 10 minutes before closing which is
incorrect so you can see from the timing
of this message when we started waiting
for our line shortly after we were
directed to the table even when we were
denied service it was still 11 36 pm we
were promised a booth a group of teens
who were not muslims came after us they
were given the booth so far it looks
plausible in the context where the
accusations that they were there when it
was about to close et cetera it goes out
the window with this evidence we were
offered two tables which we gladly took
they were right next to each other and
we asked a staff member not jessica that
staff member was wearing a red or a
maroon sweater if we can organize them
together because we had kids and family
with us and she said sure that's not a
problem now i want you to listen to this
clip where my wife mentions this to
another staff member at the counter
she said i don't think it's a problem
and we started moving them and that man
is like we can't eat here anymore
after we moved the tables with
permission jessica came over and asked
us who gave you permission to move these
tables so we pointed towards the staff
member and she said well you have to ask
a supervisor as a customer we can go
into a restaurant and ask anybody that
works there we're not going to be asking
hi can you please direct us to a
supervisor so we can move our tables if
a staff member agrees we are obviously
going to move the table now at this
point jessica mentions uh these people
that were sitting about four to five
feet away from us that look they're very
uncomfortable at that point
so um at this point i'll just talk for a
quick second um is that it's a
miscommunication because someone a staff
has said something maybe she should have
not said and due to covered restrictions
the two tables should not be joined
together even though we can say they are
family from the same family but if they
shouldn't be they shouldn't be now is it
their fault shama dresses and his
families not at all is it jessica's
fault not at all it's just a
miscommunication and anyways they move
on from that those people turned out to
be fans so they replied to jessica by
saying no we're not uncomfortable we
love their videos
hello guys uh i'm making this well here
you have the brother who's just
testifying that he was not uncomfortable
et cetera so that plays the doubt
that that may have been uncomfortable uh
in the context where maybe she said it
let's let's assume the best that jessica
may have fought this is an individual
covet is there maybe he doesn't you know
want to be close that's understandable
again i cannot blame jessica and we
cannot blame address and the rest she's
doing a job to make sure everyone feels
comfortable um so yeah and if that
wasn't their fan maybe they would have
felt uncomfortable so let's just be fair
here
let's carry on to this jessica replied
well you have to move the tables back so
we agreed and said can you please find
us a longer table so all of us can sit
together she agreed and left while
waiting peacefully i even recorded a
video of my wife and baby
sierra you can see from this video that
we have already turned the tables and we
are sitting separately in a group of six
and a group of five at this point while
sitting at the table and waiting for a
big table to be available many of my
family members took their masks and to
be honest
again just to clarify some people say
that there was 22 of them so the fact
that he's shown image which we can see
there's 11 of them there's not 22 of
them that clears that doubt for me
anyways every single person that was at
the restaurant while they were sitting
at their tables they had taken their
masks off after waiting for a little bit
we asked the supervisor if our bigger
table was ready so he directed us to a
table that was closer to the door the
entrance of dmitry's but that table was
still dirty he says go over there i'll
get the table cleaned up for you now
we're waiting at this table waiting for
it to be cleaned so we can order our
food and joseph comes and hands us a
card and says we have the right not to
serve you call our manager tomorrow and
you need to leave the restaurant to be
honest we were a little confused at this
point as to what just happened so we
went to the counter and asked what
exactly went wrong why did you guys not
want to serve us she said i don't think
it's a problem and we started moving
them and that man is like we can't
at this point another staff member that
was just making something at the back i
don't know if a milkshake or something
just passed a comment i'll be very frank
with you at this point i became very
upset when i heard that i pulled out the
camera and started recording now i want
you to closely listen to this clip
i'm not talking comfortable they don't
feel comfortable serving us because
she's wearing a hijab yeah
so is that is that yeah i'm recording
they didn't okay firstly
you're asking a question like you don't
like serving us uh because she wears a
hijab
i don't know where that came from you
haven't shown the full clip but probably
dress as brother sham uh i i don't know
where that come from it's it's as if
you're putting maybe words in a mouth
i'm not saying you are but it comes
across like that so
and she does say yeah but i don't know
if she says yeah
because she heard you or said yes to
something else or i don't know but i
very highly doubt
that a person
i was told that was owned by a muslim
owner that the person is going to come
and say
that yes we're not serving you because
she wears a
hijab and you ask her that so here it's
just a bit like
um
i don't know i'm not sure is that is
that yeah i'm recording
uh you guys what exactly did we do we
have a baby with us what exactly did we
do can you please tell us what did we do
after this the supervisor and jessica
started ignoring us and here's another
video of me standing at the counter
while they don't even acknowledge me
we asked another staff member why we
were asked to leave when we didn't do
anything this is the same clip i played
for you guys early listen closely
she said i don't think it's a problem
and we started moving them and that man
is like we can't eat here anymore
so they're calling this miscommunication
at this point they had already called
the police so the police arrived
they informed us that as of february
2021 any restaurants can ask any
customers to leave without giving them a
reason as long as it's not racism and we
said well this is racism look exactly
what happened and they said you know
it's going to be very hard for you to
prove that so we recommend you go home
call the manager tomorrow and take it up
with them at this point to be honest i
was very upset my family was very upset
but i told them to just stay calm let's
not create a fuss we'll go home i'll
take this up on social media and we'll
get them justice this isn't a case of
kovid 19 or miscommunications we were
there we saw that jessica and others
felt very uncomfortable when they were
dealing with the two hijabi girls my
wife and muhammad's mom fatima who were
dealing directly with them there was
even another hijabi woman present at
that time but
now yes there's another hijab woman
present at that time and not only that
there was someone who
claimed the story is a little bit
different she's a hijabi as well
so
to say that they discriminated because
of islamophobia
is a case that we need to really prove
uh because
it's a big it is a big claim and we
shouldn't take it lightly at all uh so
the thing is if there's a hijabi already
claiming that there's hijabi already
there and there are muslims there if
they were not felt welcome i'm sure
they would have expressed that they
would not want to serve them because
their hijabis they could have done that
all across the world i'm trying to say
so again
i'm not saying you may have not felt
like that but it's
to make that claim it's it's a big claim
this isn't the first time that this
restaurant experienced customer service
issues you can look at the reviews for
the past few years and you can see again
and again a lot of people complain about
service issues every restaurant has
service issues etc so i wouldn't
really use that if people came and said
you know what if you saw many few
hijabis in that comment section saying
you know what i was discriminated
against then i would say you've got a
case there but with people complaining
about food and service it's bound to
happen
and to all the people who are not there
or to all the people that may not have
had this first-hand experience don't
make comments on this because
islamophobia does exist look what
happened in london ontario so we
experienced it firsthand of course
islamophobia exists i'm i deal with it
firsthand but to claim that okay
somophobia exists here here here
therefore it also existed here
i wouldn't say would be fair because
just because certain things happen in
certain places doesn't mean you
being denied for whatever reason you
believe it was thermophobia they believe
it was called restrictions and other
elements um so we can't add that in
there but in a nutshell guys i just want
to give you guys a bit of reminder okay
now like i said before i don't have
anything personal against robert sham uh
idris and his wife froggy etc um and i
believe one thing that i would like to
give them as a reminder and everybody as
well is that firstly we should there's
there's a concept in islam then yeah we
should have the best of assumptions to
our believers the self would say that if
we saw our brother his beard drenched in
alcohol we'll say somebody poured it
over their head if we saw our brother in
the mountains saying i am your lord and
you are my servant we would say that he
is reading a verse of the quran the
point here is this we need to give the
benefit of the doubt to everybody yeah
okay and especially muslims as well but
also then yeah now however however one
thing that we need to say is in this
situation i'm going to i would not
accept the the the the accusations of
islamophobia that i i would like that's
a fast stretch personally yeah
i believe that there was a covert issue
etc joining tables together that
separated we have that in the uk etc so
they had right concern and a few other
elements god knows what happened you
went to other table i don't know what
happened and truth would come out when
the cameras whether it happened however
the point here is this we should have
the best assumptions now but number two
i want to give an advice to our dear
brothers
uh uh sham adries and his dear wife uh
sister froggy you need to understand
there is videos that you've done before
where it might be uh click bait it might
be things that are not true etc um and i
don't know i don't watch your guys
videos but the thing is if you
may have one i'm not understand if
there's a certain reputation that you've
built of certain things that may have
happened there was a
situation that was told to me that you
claimed the wife got punished in a
certain in pakistan or something like
that it wasn't true what happens is
people lose trust and that's why it's
very very important for us uh to build
that reputation where you know we try
not to like me i do click baits yeah i
try my clickbaits to be quiet
i don't lie in them and i try to give a
beneficial reminder when people watch it
yeah and even then people like sometimes
think oh that's a clickbait i've kind of
built that reputation in that sense i
can't really blame people if they think
ali's next video is click bait so the
point here is the following that if you
guys have done certain things that have
built a reputation towards yourself then
what people don't believe in you can we
blame them or blame ourselves that's
point number one um
point number two is like i said before
let's not use the word it's time for me
very loosely because it's a big term
people have been killed over it
people have died so the point is that we
should understand so yeah that being
said i would like to give you guys a
personal advice as well yeah this is
i've never done a video about you guys
et cetera about using this opportunity
once and for all i don't want to come
back here um is that look you guys are
social influences yeah you guys have a
big following yeah this is off topic the
soft topic yeah you guys have a big big
following and you need to understand how
you carry yourself how you conduct
yourself is a responsibility and a man
allah will ask you yeah brother idris
you know sometimes you free mix with
women yeah okay i'm not here to pick on
you i'm here to as your brother if i
care about you i'm saying have i've done
a video about this before like you said
have you ever talked about the rest of
you know you haven't have i ever talked
about you guys before i could make a
hundred excuses to just attack you guys
and i'm not attacking i'm giving a
property advice okay i have to because a
reminder benefits a believer yeah with
other women okay free mixing etc you are
social influences you need to understand
that people individuals like sister dina
tokyo and her lives even said habiba the
silva these individuals sadly the way
they portray the hijab is not the hijab
i'm so sorry you know wearing absolutely
tight clothings where you can see the
whole body you know or showing the hair
now we have a pandemic of sisters
showing their hair i'm out with my wife
and i can we see
maybe 20 or sisters who are showing
their hair their there's aura where did
this come from it started from the
emirates then dinner totally popularized
it now you have these people who are
following this the point i'm trying to
make is your actions you have people
that look up to you even you guys done a
video that you guys used to be best
friends yeah and then you get married
may allah bless your marriage and keep
you firm
but the point is this
being friends is haram it's not
permissible so when you portray this and
make it like we was friends before
you are opening the doors to zinna
indirectly i'm not saying directly
you're saying that but what you're doing
is you're making the people believe the
muslim youth you can be friends with
opposite gender the prophet peace be
upon him said if a man and a woman is
alone the third person in shaytan when
your friends
there is no i've done a social
experiment called can men and women just
be friends they can't it's impossible
forget forget the experiment what
allah's messenger told us you know so
the point is this there's certain things
that you're portraying even our dear
sister your wife you know when she was
hijab maybe a certain element she's
showing you know maybe whatever i don't
lose your wife i don't feel comfortable
going into this what i'm trying to say
is that social influences you guys have
a responsibility please please bear that
in mind i'm not here to attack you i
don't think i'm better than you maybe
you guys are 100 million times better
than me yeah maybe i'm a very corrupt
individual yeah my point here is not i'm
not coming with the holy i'm holding
thou you know i'm just trying to say
please for your
yeah for your
please please please yeah bear this in
mind and one little advice is this
yusuf alayhi salam he had a dream and
his dad told him not to share his dream
with his brothers my dear sister and
brother
you guys are sharing everything in the
entire world there are people that don't
have the positions that you have they
might be jealous that's the reason why
so many people message me that ah attack
them do this i'm not going to do that
because why do i need to do that
because i know their genuine concern is
not the right things yeah there are
people who genuinely for the sake of
allah dislike what you guys do but there
are people out there who do not like you
because why because they want what you
guys have and you showing this you are
opening the doors to evil eye and many
other things protect yourself don't show
everything out there i have hustled on
that yes you guys experiences i don't
believe you guys lied or made the drama
etc from what i considered evidence that
you probably answered quite a few doubts
however the islamophobia thing it's it's
fast stretched yeah um to make it seem i
i i can't so i'm going to be balanced
here assume the best you know i'm not
going to come and say you faked this and
did this and that i'm not going to do
that yeah so i'm just saying that
inshallah and hope you guys have
benefited brother sham and i hope i
haven't hurt you guys but it's my duty
to remind you guys that you have a
following of millions and these people
watch you guys be careful to the things
you do give the rights of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala as a reminder to
everybody that's watching this pray your
salah
give it zakah
fast in ramadan give allah's rights
abstain from major sins okay this is my
reminder to you guys inshallah and let
not and let's not allow this dunya a few
moments of the dunya to cost our archer
inshallah till next time assalamu
alaikum
goodbye